[Music]
this is a big deal for you because
you're stepping into the world of
hosting honestly when I received a call
she hosts the show I was like I'm gonna
save that for it holy is that truth I
did not believe it I swear I did not
believe it I think me really I mean with
this accent I'm like really me I do not
believe it at all only et was invited
behind the scenes of supermodel Adriana
Lima's new TV project American Beauty
star your time starts now
now now it shows what is behind the
scenes of beauty in every aspect of it
it shows the human side of it there will
be emotion good ones intense ones you
know what happens in their minds and
hearts in the whole creative process and
it's beautiful it's strong a lot of
positive positive messages to everyone
that will be watching ya think Project
Runway but for hair and makeup artists I
don't want heavy drag queen makeup
that's a different show child Helena did
you speak to your Victoria's Secret pal
Heidi Klum and get hosting tips I
thought I saw them I guess I saw them
where was it at the CFDA Awards and I
was like my question okay tell me about
it how does everything happen what has
been the most surprising part for you of
this show everything surprising whoa I
can't host the show oh my god I can't
believe it I'm here this is all about
celebrating Beauty physical beauty as a
woman raising two daughters how do you
instill in them that beauty is more than
just skin deep I think that the industry
has changed and as again at the state to
reach beauty or photography photographic
makeup or whatever creativity starts
from inside of you to your feelings from
your connection of whatever you want to
it
press so I'm so happy that the world in
beauty in fashion in my opinion has
changed and everyone wants to feel
connected with the person behind the
makeup or whatever the picture my
children there is a lot of positive
messages in fashion and in beauty and
those messages are the ones that I will
embrace and our ring force into my
children's lives would you be okay if
your daughters went into modelling went
into this industry oh yes I think that's
a way I have one possible candidate I
won't name her because I don't know if
she may change her mind and I don't want
her to have pressure from everyone out
there okay so there is a possibility and
whatever is a decision I will be right
there as supportive they're so little
though yes but you know the kids have
changed they know what they like they
don't like they know what they want
where they want to go they know
everything yeah
you